i have offers but if i were to like
really look at i was talking to
somebody was asking for asking acting
advice which i always think is hard
because i think it's such a hard
business and so much stuff is
is his lottery and like placement and
people you know and then if you're in
the door
and you happen to be pleasant and
somewhat good at your job you may get
you might get hired again right yeah but
there's so little that you control
so i said to them you almost have to
love it to a point of a bit of a
masochism like it's like you can't stop
yourself from
doing it again and again and again you
know so like same thing with auditions i
don't know how many years it's gone
since stuff i've auditioned for i
haven't gotten
but it's been years
so who's the masochist like i just go
it's like running and hitting your head
against the wall sure i'll do it again
yeah sure i'll do it again i mean that's
all i can say to people that
like how do i get into the business
you just keep doing it because you love
it and then you find caveats like
different types of ways that you can
enjoy it um
people you know always tell me
that i have a good voice and i should do
more voice-over work and i'm like yeah i
know okay thanks i'm over 63
in my last 63 uh auditions my voiceover
auditions i just never get them i never
get there and you don't even know why
because
i i just it's so random
it's so random
i remember sitting in for like some of
the stuff on saving hope and i was just
like
some of the reasons for people not to
get hired it was just crushing to me i
was just like
that person just like
they did the best they could they did a
great job i know exactly what they were
going through when they went out and it
was like
meh
i just didn't like him
you just don't like him like that's
that's the reason somebody just get a
job i'll tell you what they say that
they say that when you walk into a room
they know immediately if you're right
for the part or not you walk in like
nope let's just read them and get them
going i don't care how hard he worked
for it i don't get unless you're you
know gary oldman and you go in there and
also you give them something that
they're like wait a minute this guy just
gave us such brilliance that we have to
consider it but they say they know
you're not
or you happen to be like i knew that
there was a guy that was around for a
while that like
he would hire these girls they all look
dissimilar and it was just like they
were hot like his wife
and so they all got jobs and not that
they weren't talented they surely were
good at their job but they also happened
to remind him
of his wife and then a few years later
he didn't like his wife and so you
wouldn't want to remind him of his wife
like those are random things as an actor
you can't control
wow i didn't think about it like that
right yeah i mean what if it reminds you
like some hot girl from from the 20 that
they ate in their 20s and then just like
i just like
you